this week on brian ross investigate
messing with our water an attempt to
contaminate the drinking water in a
florida town
reveals a gaping national vulnerability
investigators are trying to hunt down
the person who tried to poison
a public water supply remotely who's
guarding the safety of our water
our electricity the former u.s cyber
counter-terrorist
richard clark with some disturbing
answers if you
retaliate against china if you retaliate
against russia they can turn out the
lights in new york
or they can stop the water flowing in
houston
plus the secret life of teenagers during
the covet 19 lockdown
growing concern about a rash of suicides
we've seen several suicides in
recent weeks of public school kids that
is very very painful
a year of no proms no graduations no
sports
but lots of cheating they're feeling
unmotivated
they do cheat in order to get by
and this week's winners and losers in
the media
see if you agree with the choices from
the editors of mediaite
how do you justify leaving in the middle
of all this instead of getting out there
and seeing what you can do with your
with your hands to help from the law and
crime
trial network this is brian ross
investigates good evening and thank you
for joining us and welcome to our
friends on facebook live
i'm brian ross joined by my colleague at
law and crime rhonda schwartz
and rhonda we begin with troubling
questions about the safety
and security of our water and power
supply
we've seen the vulnerabilities of those
two essentials in texas as a
deep winter storm hit there with a deep
freeze
raising questions about that state but
even more troubling perhaps was a little
noticed event in florida where officials
discovered someone had hacked into the
computers
of the water district and tried to add
dangerous chemicals
to the water supply ronda that's right
the fbi and local authorities are now
investigating a cyber attack
on the water treatment plant in the
small town of oldsmar florida
a very alert engineer spotted an
electronic intruder trying to take over
the control panel
and was quickly able to shut it down and
prevent what appeared to be an effort to
poison the water supply brian
now to a shocking case of computer
hacking in pinellas county florida
investigators are trying to hunt down
the person who tried to
poison a public water supply remotely
hacker gains access to the computer
system that controls the water supply
for a small
city the system was only breached for
about five minutes but in that time the
hacker was able to increase
the amount of a dangerous chemical in
the water thankfully a plant operator
noticed the system being accessed
remotely
and quickly caught on to the potentially
harmful change and reverted the levels
we're joined now by richard clark the
country's one-time cyber czar and a
leading expert on cyber terrorism
mr clark thanks for being here this
evening when we see what happened in
tampa it is a wake-up call
to what can happen with cyber terrorism
the real threat every american may face
well that's right brian but this is
something that we've known about for
almost three decades a presidential
commission
reported in 1998 that water systems
could be attacked
over the internet uh and other things
have happened since then
to prove them right the russians
attacked the ukrainian electric
power grid and turned off the lights in
half of the country
russia appears to have figured out how
to crash a power grid
with a click nearly a quarter of a
million people
lost power in this small ukrainian city
when it was targeted by a suspected
russian attack last december so we know
not only theoretically
utilities can be attacked over the
internet but in fact they have been
and yet brian despite all of that
over the last 30 years almost the u.s
government has not
regulated public utilities in a way
that makes them secure and how
vulnerable are they at this point
well it varies uh i think the gas
pipelines
uh are much more vulnerable uh
than the others i think some big city
water systems are fairly secure
but small towns like this place in
florida are not
uh and the problem with the the water
systems
is that in addition to providing us with
water
they have many of them large tanks of
chlorine gas
which they use in small amounts to
purify the water
now chlorine gas you might recall from
history
is what was used in world war one by the
germans and the british
to kill each other it was a chemical
weapon
and so if somehow you can get into
the controls of a local uh water system
and open the valves uh of the chlorine
gas
and let that cloud float out into the
community
you have a lethal situation the hacker
changed the sodium hydroxide
from about 100 parts per million to 11
100 parts per million this is obviously
a significant and potentially dangerous
increase
sodium hydroxide also known as lye is
the main ingredient in liquid drain
cleaners
what do you make of the effort in
florida was that a amateur was that
somebody who knew what they were doing
well certainly somebody knew what they
were doing but they might also be
amateur
uh i i don't think necessarily that was
a state
actor uh i i recall situations where we
thought
attacks were state actors and when we
actually ran it to ground we found
in 14 year old boys so
you can never tell with this kind of an
attack it's not that sophisticated
that it has to be a state actor but you
know the electric power grids also vary
in in the quality of their security uh
some of the bigger companies
um southern california edison
con ed in new york uh they're fairly
secure
but there are as a result of
deregulation thousands
of electric power companies that
generate or transmit
and the although there are rules
about cyber security they're not really
audited by any third party auditor
occasionally somebody sees a violation
and a fine is imposed but there's not a
real rigorous system of hunting down
vulnerabilities
we saw last year a discovery that
transformers big giant electrical
transformers
being used on the power grid that were
made in china
have a back door in them that allows the
chinese to come in over the internet and
get into the transformers
and these transformers are on our grid
throughout the country
what worries you more the big state
actors russia china perhaps iran
or criminal groups that might try to use
extortion to get money out of doing all
this
i worry most about the big state actors
i think if
if there were ever a conflict or a
crisis
uh let's imagine the crisis between
china and the us
over taiwan uh or the south china sea
or hong kong now let's imagine a crisis
between
us and russia over poland or latvia or
ukraine
uh or or some crazy idea like the
russians interfering in our election
uh you know if there were a crisis and
we needed to retaliate
i think the president needs to be told
the person who who has the job today
that i used to have
will have to walk into the president and
say president biden if you retaliate
against china if you retaliate against
russia in these ways
they can turn out the lights in new york
or they can
stop the water flowing in houston so
it creates an entirely different dynamic
and from your point of view do you think
they are
in there already oh yeah i do you do uh
i do and you know the the last
administration
uh actually leaked intentionally leaked
from the white house the fact that we're
probably doing the same thing to them
okay so we're probably in the russian
power grid
now let's say they turn off our power
grid and keep it off by
exploding the transformers and exploding
the generators
and we do it back to them well
as the people of texas know this week
not having electric power in winter is
pretty awful
and the fact that you've imposed that
same level of suffering
on the people of moscow or the people of
beijing doesn't make you
in houston any warmer
i joked once that you know if we and the
russians do this to each other
they'll have the advantage because at
least they have a lot of vodka
so who would be the first to pull the
trigger in a situation like that or is
there sort of a mutually assured
destruction well so the advocates of
cyber
war say it's mutually assured
destruction then this is a good thing
uh people like me however worry that it
creates what we call
crisis instability it creates an
incentive
in a crisis situation to go first
and that's the kind of dynamic that you
never want
that when a crisis is escalating
one side thinks i have to pull the
trigger before he does
uh or she does that's um that's a recipe
for a a major a major situation
all right well quite the wake up call
richard clark thank you so much for
being here this evening
thank you brian
coming up next the secret lives of
teenagers during the covet 19 pandemic
loneliness anxiety cheating suicides
we'll talk to a leading child
psychologist you're watching brian ross
investigates on the law and crime
trial network
it's been almost a year now since the
country went into a covet 19
lockdown tough for everyone especially
teenagers who have been cut off from
friends and teachers facing new social
and academic challenges
and child psychologists say they've seen
a disturbing spike in anxiety depression
and suicides something the mayor of new
york
took note of we've seen
uh several suicides in recent weeks
of public school kids that is very very
painful and i'm speaking now
not only as mayor but as a parent the
fact that these kids have gone through
this crisis
the trauma they've felt many kids have
lost loved ones
many kids are feeling really isolated in
the absence
of you know the regular rhythms of their
life and particularly
the absence of school for some of them
this is why it's imperative we bring
back
school as quickly as possible we're
joined now by karen mosk a child
psychologist in maryland
karen thanks for being here teenage
years are always full of angst but
particularly during a pandemic
what's happening with teenagers hi brian
thank you so much for having me
the kids that i know the kids that i see
in my practice are having
a lot of difficulty for for multiple
reasons
um first you know teenagers don't really
have the sense of perspective
that adults have teenagers feel
that now is the only time they can't
imagine
life in the future the way adults sort
of look back and see
okay it's gonna change teenagers really
feel like
now is forever um and now is hard
um they're isolated they feel that
they're not
um having success in school or socially
so that lack of perspective
is one of the reasons why i'm seeing a
huge increase in depression and anxiety
among
our teens one study found that a quarter
of all teenagers had suicidal thoughts
we've seen the spike in suicides in new
york and elsewhere
do they talk about that with you yes um
it's one of the things that i ask
everybody that i see
in the past i didn't have to necessarily
look at suicidal ideology
as deeply as i do now but the sense of
things not getting better the sense of
isolation feeling
unsuccessful has really caused a lot of
despair
the good news is is that kids are
they're able to get better they're able
to as long as they can connect
and talk to somebody usually they can
find
purpose they just have to do it in a
different way at this point
is there any good news in all this does
the fact that they're not in the high
pressure cooker situation
of classrooms is that a plus in any way
it can be um in my experience there has
been
there are different types of kids there
are the
very high achievers who are focused on
their grades
and for those kids it has
released some of that pressure they
continue to do well
they're continuing to do everything that
they're asked but they don't have the
intensity of getting up very early
or late nights of homework they're
getting more sleep
more family time and so for those kids
there is
there has been a slight benefit um but
for
for many kids achievement is an issue
because they're not ex they're not
internally driven
for grades and usually kids
who aren't internally driven to get
those top grades
want to achieve because of the
relationships that they have with their
teachers
they want to achieve because of
eligibility status at schools
um they want to achieve because the kids
around them also want to achieve and
when you take
all of those things away we've seen a
lot of kids sinking academically
and has this led to any sort of cheating
do they do their work
are they are they turning in their
papers
there's a lot of cheating going on right
now
and um kids feel like
they're not learning um the kids that i
see some of them feel that they're not
learning because they're not paying
attention they're feeling
unmotivated um they do cheat
um in order to get by and we talk a lot
about how this is just
a crisis year um kids will recover
academically
i'm not as concerned about that um it's
the kids who aren't
doing their work they're not completing
the tasks and those kids
actually are failing um i don't know how
many
but uh certainly in my practice i'm
seeing some of that
so karen for the parents this must be
also a hard time if they don't quite
understand what's happening with their
teenagers
yes what i found brian is that a lot of
kids have feelings they don't understand
and
cannot articulate that to their parents
and sometimes i get a call
from a parent who knows something is off
but isn't sure exactly what's wrong
and when i meet with a child i'm very
surprised at the depth of their feelings
and so there is a even though you're
around
your children as much as you are or your
children are around you as much as they
are
there is a disconnect on in terms of
understanding
each other's perspectives so there is
sort of a secret world for some
teenagers
yes and it's not so much that they're
hiding it from their parents although of
course some of them
are it's that they don't even understand
exactly what they're feeling
and there is a sense of shame around
that
all right very good advice karen moss
child psychologist in maryland
thank you so much for joining us tonight
thank you so much brian
coming up next this week's winners and
losers in the media
including the texas reporters who chased
after the senator who is now and forever
known
as cancun cruz you're watching brian
ross investigates on the law and crime
trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media
as chosen by the editors of mediaite and
we're joined by aidan mclaughlin who's
the editor-in-chief of mediaite
which like the law and crime trial
network is part of the dan abrams media
company
aiden we begin with the winner the
reporters in texas who went on the hunt
for ted cruz the senator
who took off for cancun in the midst of
a crisis there
earning the nickname cancun cruz they
pressed him hard
about why he had gone
people whose children don't have heat
and power
how do you justify leaving in the middle
of all this instead of getting out there
and seeing what you can do with your
with your hands to help well look
in hindsight if i'd understood
how it would be perceived the reaction
people would have obviously i wouldn't
have done it it was a mistake
what do you make of that response aiden
the texas reporters were very aggressive
in going after senator cruz
yes this is one of those old school
political scandals i think
uh that is really well suited for local
reporting like that
um you know in the history books it'll
be in the same chapter as chris christie
getting caught
enjoying an empty beach in new jersey
during a government shutdown
but local texas reporters were really
instrumental in reporting the story out
um and you have to i think put into
context that these newsrooms were
reporting last week during a devastating
winter storm and power outage
that rocked the state and so they're
working under these really tough
conditions
and you still had a throng of local
reporters
uh that were you know engaging the
time-tested tradition of
showing up at a politician's doorstep to
confront them on their screw-up
um that video that we just showed you
know was an
abc 13 uh reporter grilling ted cruz
about
the decision to leave to cancun while
his state was dealing with this crisis
um but there was also this great uh
interview that ted cruz got
with a gaggle of reporters where they
were grilling him outside of his home in
texas
about the decision to flee the state and
i think in an era when
you know you have so much hyper partisan
siloed media where ted cruz can just
appear on fox news for an interview with
sean hannity and not get questioned
about this stuff
it's always heartwarming as someone that
covers the media to know that a
politician will still face
tough questions on their doorstep from
local reporters
indeed and now this week's losers greg
kelly at newsmax
who had the courage to go after not the
president of the united states
but to go after his dogs millie
had like a staff and they really took
care of her very beautiful dog
this dog looks like from i'm sorry from
the junkyard and i love that dog
but he looks like he's not been well
cared for no not not at all
thank you for having us uh no he looks
very dirty and disheveled and uh
very unlike a presidential dog so aidan
what do you make of that an attack on
the
first dogs well so
greg kelly uh believe it or not is the
star
anchor of newsmax uh he's the primetime
host over there
uh and newsmax is of course a uh
pro-trump uh conservative tv outlet that
has been challenging fox news in recent
months
um you know i think the segment in which
kelly attacked
joe biden's dog as dirty and even
brought on two historians
to join him in a pretty absurd segment
about it
is good evidence that the network is not
really ready for prime time and then
when it has a bunch of
eyes on it watching it um you you really
realize that it has segments like that
which come off as sort of amateurish
and a little insane um so yeah i think
it's worth remembering that this is a
this is a prime time show
on a news network um let's not get that
lost uh that is actually challenging fox
news right now
and they're struggling to stay ahead
they had some momentum after the
election but they seemed to have lost
that a bit
they have lost that a bit you know right
after the election when trump supporters
which is a really huge and engaged
audience
uh were jumping ship from fox news and
going to newsmax
mainly because fox news despite all of
its support for the president
was not engaging in the fantasy that
trump had actually won the election
until it was stolen from him
newsmax was they were holding out hope
particularly hosts like greg kelly
and he saw his ratings surge because he
was selling that lie to viewers
um that has ceded from the view now that
joe biden is obviously president
and their ratings have gone down in the
aftermath
so he yeah so now they're gonna go after
the dogs we don't know who's next aiden
thanks so much for being here today
thanks to all of you for watching and
thanks to the staff at long crime for
getting us on the air
and off the air
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you